[Musique]
et
oh
le haut
[Musique]
chaque année à présenter aux
martiniquais ce que suppose impulsif et
de mieux dans l'événementiel avec
l'organisation des ces festivals il
commence avec le festival de jazz
ensuite le festival du carnaval le roots
and swell qui va mal
après et ensuite le mois du créole le
mois d'octobre donc le festival de jazz
on va commencer avec lui c'est du 7 au 9
mai avec un line up extraordinaire
d'artistes internationaux et on reçoit
cette année
mayer bon roi de la partie qui fera
partie de ces trois jours de festival où
c'est pour neuf les ensuite le carnaval
c'est très très important pour nous
d'inviter les martiniquais non seulement
à regarder le carnaval mais essaye
d'anticiper et voilà donc à chaque à
chaque habitation
on fait comme ça le public répond
toujours présent et nous c'est un
plaisir pour nous de recevoir tous par
exemple cette soirée d'hier
l'annoncé est ouverte
m
[Musique]
bon
oh
et
[Musique]